Okay. Okay, danke schön. Guten Tag, mein Name ist Satije Delibas.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzerstin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmigespreis führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay. Okay. Wie heißen Sie das?
Das heißt Hans Weber. Hans Weber. Weber.
Fühlen Sie es langsam und deutlich, buchstabieren.
Weil der Vorname ist Hans H-A-N-S. Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Weber. W-E-B-E-R.
Okay. Okay. Herr Weber.
Bin ich einmal, ne? Genau.
Herr Weber. Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Weber?
Ich bin noch 64 Jahre alt.
64 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie geboren?
1664.
1960.
Okay. Ich werde also in Kürze 65.
Okay. Okay, Herr Weber.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin alt 78.
78. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich schuldige.
Ich wiege 92 kg.
99 kg.
Okay. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ähm, ich muss, ja klar, ich habe also jahrelang als Kraftfahrer gearbeitet.
Aber in letzter Zeit fällt mir das zunehmend schwer.
Ich bin jetzt kurz vor der Rente und ja, es wird ein bisschen anstrengend langsam.
Kraftfahrer.
Kraftfahrer, ja.
Also LKW, ne?
LKW Kraftfahrer.
Mhm.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ähm, in Köln.
In Köln. Okay.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarztin?
Äh, Dr. Schräder.
Schräder?
Mhm.
Okay.
Äh, Herr Weber, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, ne?
Ja, wir haben vier Kinder.
Äh, wie viele Kinder?
Vier.
Vier Kinder?
Mhm.
Ja, sehr.
Meine Großfamilie, ja.
Ja, sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, gut.
Sehr gut.
Okay, Herr Weber, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ach wissen Sie, ich habe seit einiger Zeit, habe ich immer schon so Schmerzen in den Beinen.
Und, ähm, das so insbesondere in der rechten Wade und im rechten Unterschenkel.
Und, äh, ja, die Schmerzen, die, die kommen halt, wenn ich, wenn ich laufe, ja.
Und, äh, nach einer Weile, wenn ich dann stehenbleibe, dann wird es eigentlich besser, dann kann ich wieder weitergehen, ja.
Aber, äh, jetzt muss ich also tatsächlich, ist schon noch ein paar hundert Metern,
muss ich immer so einen kleinen Augenblick stehenbleiben
und dann kann es wieder weitergehen.
Und beim Treppelaufen ist es natürlich auch, ja.
Wenn ich dann, also von der Luft her denke ich mal, kann ich das schaffen, ja.
Ich bin gar nicht luftnötig oder so, also ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich zu schlapp bin,
sondern nur das rechte Bein, ja.
Oh, das will überhaupt nicht mitmachen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das habe ich eigentlich schon seit mehreren Wochen, aber, ähm, das wird halt immer schlimmer, ne?
Am Anfang habe ich immer so gedacht, ja, also,
ja gut, äh, Bein tut ein bisschen weh, bis halt ein bisschen lange unterwegs gewesen.
Ich bin natürlich auch viel, sitze ich viel im Auto, also auch meinem, ne, meinem Lkw.
Und wenn ich dann mal aufstehe, ähm, und mal eine Strecke gehe, ja, das sind immer nur kurze Strecken, ja.
Und wenn ich dann mal längere Touren zurücklegen muss, wenn ich am Wochenende mit meiner Frau spazieren will oder so, ne.
Ja, dann merke ich mit einem mal, oh, das geht gar nicht so gut,
denke ich immer, ja, bis es nicht gewöhnt.
Aber jetzt ist es eben schon so, nach kurzer Zeit käme das an, ja.
Äh, ja, gibt es etwas, äh, Ihre Schmerzen, äh, verlindert oder verstärkt?
Sie haben gesagt, äh, beim Laufen?
Ja, wenn ich laufe, geht's, ne, aber, und wenn ich dann stehen bleibe, dann geht es wieder weg, dann wird es besser.
Geht es wieder weg, äh, und haben Sie Luftnot, Luftnotik, Sie haben Ihnen gesagt?
Ja, nee, also nicht, gar, also, wenn ich, ich habe gesagt, wenn ich Treppen laufe, ja, andere Leute sagen,
ich komme die Treppe nicht hoch, weil ich keine Luft bekomme.
Ich kann die Treppe nicht hochlaufen, weil mein Bein wehtut.
Ja, vielleicht sei ich.
Äh, okay, im Laufe der Zeit vermehrt diese.
Ja, das hat sich, das hat sich immer verschlechtert, genau.
Mhm, ja, ich habe verstanden.
Äh, okay, haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Ja, also, was mir aufgefallen ist, dass das Bein eben auch manchmal sich ein bisschen kühl anfühlt, ja, und so ganz blass ist.
Manchmal kühl anfühlt.
Mhm, ja, äh, ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, hab ich doch eigentlich gerade gesagt, dass ich keine Atemnot habe.
Haben Sie höchstens, oder?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen in den Beinen.
Nur Schmerzen, Sie haben.
Ja, ja, aber ordentlich.
Nur rechte Beine, oder?
Nicht linke.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nur rechte Beine.
Okay, äh, ich habe verstanden, seit mehreren Wochen, Sie haben Bein-Schmerzen im rechte Wade unterschenken.
Wenn Sie laufen, kommt diese Schmerzen.
Nein, keine Luftnot.
Das habe ich ja versucht, Ihnen so sagen.
Andere Leute können die Treppe nicht laufen, weil Sie keine Luft bekommen.
Ich kann die Treppe nicht laufen, weil mein Bein wehtut.
Okay, okay, entschuldigung.
Ja, äh, ich habe ja auch gesagt, dass ich keine Luft bekommen kann.
Ich kann keine Luft bekommen, weil mein Bein wehtut.
Ja, okay, okay, entschuldigung.
Ja, äh, ich habe gesagt, dass ich keine Luft bekommen kann.
Ja, äh, okay, wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das sind meine Probleme, genau.
Okay, okay Herr Weber, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, in meinem Alter, das wäre ja ein Wunder, wenn ich nichts hätte.
Ich habe halt ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und ja, ich habe auch diesen Alterszucker.
Ich habe das mal festgestellt.
Also, festgestellt hat man das vor 10 Jahren.
Vor 10 Jahren?
Ja.
Alterszucker.
Genau.
Seit wann haben Sie Alterszucker?
Ja, vor 15 Jahren hat man das mal festgestellt.
Ich bin ja natürlich auch ein bisschen, ich habe ein bisschen zu viel Gewicht.
Das weiß ich auch, aber das hängt natürlich auch an der Arbeit.
Wenn man die ganze Zeit LKW sitzt, dann muss man zwischendurch dann auch mal das Essen.
Ja, und da hat man nicht viel Bewegung.
Sie können nicht gut behandelt, vielleicht, oder?
Genau.
Vor 15 Jahren festgestellt, Sie haben gesagt, oder, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe?
Was waren Sie, der Alterszucker?
Alterszucker, das hat man so vor 15 Jahren, ungefähr, festgestellt.
Vor 15 Jahren, okay, okay.
Haben Sie andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, mein Arzt hat mir eben auch gesagt, dass ich ein bisschen zu viel Blutfettwerte habe.
Blutfettwerte?
Ja, und ich nehme jetzt halt gegen den Blutdruck, nehme ich Tabletten
und auch für den Zucker, nehme ich Tabletten.
Aber ich musste da noch nie irgendwie mehr machen.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, ich nehme immer mit Formin eine Tablette nur.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie Hochblutfettwerte, Ihre Blutwerte sind hoch.
Wann ist das festgestellt?
Ja, das hat man, glaube ich, damals so zusammen mit dem hohen Blutdruck festgestellt, also so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr.
Vor zehn Jahren, okay.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, also, ich hatte einen Bandscheibenvorfall, ja, zu viel gesessen, zu viel gehoben
und da bin ich halt am Rücken einmal operiert worden, ja.
Wann haben Sie operiert? Wann wohl ganz wie operiert?
Das ist schon ziemlich lange herab, das ist bestimmt fast 20 Jahre her.
Okay, rechte Bein oder linke Bein?
Eine Bandscheibenvorfall.
Ja, Bandscheibenvorfall, okay.
Okay, andere, Sie haben keine andere Operiertöne.
Sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden, nein.
Okay, Herr Weber, gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Blutdruck?
Also, meine Mutter hat auch diesen Zucker, den Alterszucker
und die ist natürlich auch schon sehr alt, die ist ja weit über 80
und die ist pflegebedürftig und mein Vater, der lebt nicht mehr.
Lebt ihr Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, die ist aber natürlich sehr alt und die ist auch pflegebedürftig
und mein Vater, der hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Lebt nicht mehr, nein, er ist gestorben daran.
Okay, hatte er andere Vorarl-Grogn, Sie hatten nicht einen?
Ja, ich weiß nur, dass er letztendlich einen Herzinfarkt bekommen hat.
Wissen Sie, die Eltern leben nicht hier am Ort oder lebten nicht hier am Ort
und ich war eben immer unterwegs, ich habe da nicht viel von mitbekommen.
Ich kann Ihnen also nicht sagen, was da sonst war.
Ja, ich weiß.
Wie geht es Ihnen, Schwester?
Nein, ich habe keine Schwester.
Keine Schwester, okay Herr Weber.
Wie geht es Ihnen, Ihre Körpertemperatur zu beenden?
Ne, ich fühle mich aber auch nicht fieberig.
Ich habe halt diese Beinschmerzen, aber sonst habe ich einen...
Ich habe mich gemessen, oder?
Ich habe mich gemessen, nee.
Okay, haben Sie Schütterfrost oder Nachtschirmais?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, wenn ich sehr spät schlafen gehe, weil ich noch bis spät gearbeitet habe,
dann kann ich manchmal nicht gut einschlafen,
aber normalerweise bin ich so müde, dass ich gut schlafen kann.
Manchmal haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen.
Ja, wenn ich bis kurz vorher gearbeitet habe, ne?
Ah, ja.
Ja, okay Herr Weber.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit bei sich gewünscht veränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, schön wärs, aber nein, ich wiege immer so viel.
Sie haben nicht bemerkt.
Okay, leiden Sie wieder Appetitlosigkeit?
Nein, wirklich nicht.
Nein, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit einem Strückang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, kann ich nicht sagen.
Herr Weber, haben Sie Stress in Ihrem Leben?
Ja, also meine Arbeit ist natürlich schon sehr stressig, ne?
Und ich bin froh, dass ich also bald auf die Rente zugehe, das kann man nicht ewig machen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente.
Sie haben gesagt, Metformin Sie nehmen.
Ja, ich nehme Metformin, ja, genau, und Ramipril, ne?
Metformin und Ramipril.
Für den Blutdruck, ne?
Ja, wie viel Milligramm und...
Das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen, ich weiß dann nur, dass ich eine morgens und eine abends nehme,
aber was da draufsteht, ich weiß nur, dass die Ramipril heißen.
Ramipril, wie viel Milligramm?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, Ramipril auch morgens und abends, oder?
Ja, genau.
Noch andere Medikamente, Sie nehmen nicht andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, also wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, oder so, nehme ich mal Aspirin,
aber damit ich halt weiterarbeiten kann, aber normalerweise...
Sie nehmen Aspirin bei mir da.
Okay, Herr Weber, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider, ja, schon eigentlich mein ganzes Leben lang,
also ein Päckchen am Tag rauche ich schon.
Seit wann rauchen Sie und wie viel?
Hab ich gerade gesagt, ein Päckchen am Tag, 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Ein Pick-up am Tag.
Ja, seit wann?
Seit ich erwachsen bin, also seit über 40 Jahren.
Seit über 40 Jahren.
Too long, eh.
Haben Sie versucht aufzuhören?
Ach, wissen Sie bei den Beruf, da kann man ohne Zigaretten nicht gut auskommen.
Ja, ich empfehle Ihnen aufzuhören.
Ja, wenn das mal so einfach wäre, ja.
Ja, ich hoffe, Sie können das schaffen.
Twinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, solange ich arbeite natürlich nicht, aber abends nach Feierabend
bin ich schon gerne mal ein Bier.
Oder auch wenn es etwas zu Feiern gibt, trinken wir auch mal ein Bier und Schnaps oder so, aber also,
ich kann mir das nicht erlauben, viel zu trinken.
Jeden Tag trinken Sie nicht.
Nein, nein.
Nur im Feierabend.
Am Feierabend, wenn es Feste gibt, ja, genau.
Also am Feierabend, jetzt im Winter auch eigentlich eher kein Bier, aber wie gesagt,
wenn es etwas zu Feier gibt, trinken wir schon Bier und Schnaps zu Hause
und nach Feierabend eben auch hin und wieder malen wir.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Das ist gut.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich bitte.
Das ist nur eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein, nein, das kann man sich wirklich nicht erlauben.
Nein, da habe ich auch nie probiert.
Ja, das ist gut.
Haben Sie allergie, die bestimmte Substanz oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe wirklich eine Allergie, das hat man mal gemerkt bei einem Incheck,
dass ich auch Pelzillin allergisch reagiere.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Ja, ich kriegte also so ein rotes Gesicht und mir wurde ganz heiß
und ich kriegte so einen jubenden Hautausschlag und da haben wir das ganz schnell abgesetzt.
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Das war es oder?
Ja, sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Ich kann eigentlich alles essen und zu mir nehmen, was ich will, ja.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Ja, ich denke, ich habe alle für mich relevante Fragen gestattet.
Gibt es noch etwas, das Sie mir sagen möchten?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich wissen, was wir jetzt mit den Beinen machen.
Das tut mir ja so weh.
Ich kann nicht jetzt Ihnen eine genaue Diagnose geben.
Zuerst muss ich die Körperhüter untersuchen, dann habe ich einige Label untersucht.
Dann vielleicht Bildgebänden verfahren, die wir durchführen.
Dockler, Ultraschall, zum Beispiel.
Und tut das weh?
Nein, das ist schmerzfrei.
Nein, das ist so gut.
Ja, wir können die Gefäße von Ihren Beinen mit dieser Untersuchung beurteilen.
Und schmerzfrei und strahlungsfrei.
Das klingt ja gut, ja.
Ja, machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Und es dauert auch nicht lange, ne?
Nein, nicht so viel, fünf Minuten, das dauert fünf Minuten, in der Regel kann es dauern.
Ja, ich werde jetzt mit meinem Chef sprechen, danach komme ich gleich wieder.
Nehmen Sie Platz im Warteraum.
Okay, dann gehe ich darüber.
Okay, ja, da warte ich auf Sie, danke schön.
Okay, gerne.
Ja, ich habe das glaube ich gesagt, nach 200 Meter, 2 bis 300 Meter fangen die Schmerzen an.
Wie bitte?
Es wurde eine Frage hier reingestellt, trifft mich.
Und die Frage war, wie lange können Sie ohne Schmerzen gehen?
Und da habe ich halt gesagt, 2 bis 300 Meter, das habe ich aber auch Ihnen erzählt.
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Weber.
Ja, bitte.
Sind die Schmerzen bei Hochlagerung des Beins besser geworden?
Bei Hochlagerung werden die nicht besser bleiben.
Okay, danke.
Ah, ja, hier kommen noch interessante Fragen rein.
Haarausfall am rechten Bein ist mir noch nicht aufgefallen.
Habe ich aber auch nicht drauf geachtet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, dass das irgendwie so kalt und weiß ist das Bein, also so hellere Haut.
Und dann war hier noch schriftlich die Frage drin, ob ich einen Unfall gehabt habe.
Gott sei Dank habe ich keinen Unfall gehabt.
Und haben Sie Traubreizgefühl in deinem Bein?
Das habe ich eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ist Ihr Bein geschwollt?
Ja, rechte in den Seiten.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass das dicker ist als das andere.
Ach ja, also jemand fragt, ob ich Krampf addern habe, ist ich nicht.
Und Schmerzintensität, das haben Sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt, Frau Dr. Yelda Basti.
Ja, Schmerzgala hat ja schon ordentliche Schmerzen, 6 bis 8 von 10.
Im Momentan?
Im Momentan habe ich keine Schmerzen, ich laufe ja nicht.
Also keine ruhige Schmerzen.
Ich habe keine schlechteilenden Wunden, nein.
Ja, Schmerzgala habe ich gerade gesagt und ich habe keine offene Wunde am Bein.
Aber wenn ich mich mal, also im Augenblick habe ich keine,
wenn ich mich mal gestoßen habe, so bei der Arbeit, an der Palette oder so,
das ist mir schon aufgefallen, dass das am Unterschenkel nicht gut heilt.
Und hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden für Rech schon einmal?
Nein, das ist eigentlich jetzt erst seit einigen Wochen,
das habe ich als junger Mann nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay, danke.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, können Sie Ihre Fragen im Chat schreiben,
aber bitte sagen Sie Ihre Fragen sprachlich, müdlich.
Ah ja, man muss schnell sein, wenn man das lesen will, das ist das Problem.
Ja, hier kam gerade die Frage nach Herzrasen, Herzklopfen.
Da hat die Frau Dr. Delibas ja eigentlich ziemlich intensiv nachgefragt
und da hat der Patient so ein bisschen unwirsch reagiert.
Da hat sie gesagt, ich bin wegen meinem Bein hier, was wollen Sie denn so?
Ja, und er hat ja auch so ein bisschen angegeben, ich könnte die Treppe luftnötig,
bin ich nicht, ich kann die Treppe gut wohnen, meine Kumpels, die pumpen alle,
aber ich kann wegen meines Beines da nicht hoch.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Bauchschmerzen oder Brustschmerzen haben?
Nein, nein, ist ihm nicht aufgefallen, er hat Beinschmerzen.
Punkt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig ist, aber wann haben Sie zugenommen?
Mein Gewicht habe ich schon ewig lange, also seit ich Lkw-Fahrer bin,
da bin ich ein bisschen übergewichtig.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben, sind Sie dumm oder stichend drückend?
Sie sind, meine ich, drückend stichend.
Haben Sie eine Farbveränderung oder Rötungen, im rechten Bein bemerkt?
Ja, habe ich auch schon gesagt, dass ich eine Bresse bemerkt habe.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Ecole strottprobleme?
Auch das habe ich schon gesagt.
Ja, er hat angegeben, dass er erhöhte Blumfettwerte hat, ja.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Es waren viele Fragen, aber auch einige Sachen, die wirklich schon geklärt waren, meine ich.
Denn Frau Deliver hat ja eigentlich ziemlich intensiv gefragt,
und eigentlich fast alle Entscheidenden, was sie mich nicht gefragt hat, ob ich geimpft bin.
Ja, ich habe ja.
Aber sonst würde ich sagen, sind alle Sachen auf dem Zettel abgefragt worden,
aber ansonsten würde ich sagen,
haben Sie eigentlich ziemlich intensiv schon gefragt?
Ja, was meinen Sie?
Dadurch, dass so viele Fragen kamen, hatten Sie ein bisschen Zeit vorzubereiten?
Mögen Sie jetzt schon als Arztgespräch machen?
Ja.
Wunderbar, dann starten wir.
Ich bin nicht sicher, aber ich hoffe, ich kann machen.
Hallo, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen,
Hans Weber.
Er ist 64 Jahre alt,
er ist 1,78 Meter groß
und 92 kg schwer.
Er ist ein Kraftfahrer, er wohnt in Könn,
er ist ein Verheirateter und ist eine Kinder.
Seit mehreren Wochen haben er Rechtebeinschmerzen
und Schmerzen im rechten Bein.
Ja, Schmerzen im rechten Bein.
Im Ganzen Bein?
Nein, im Rechten Bein.
Im Laufe derseits, diese Schmerzen verschlimmert.
Haben sich die Schmerzen verschlimmert?
Ja.
Wenn Sie laufen, er könne nicht lange laufen.
Wenn Sie laufen auf dem Treppen, kommt diese Schmerzen.
Er kann nicht lange laufen.
Wie ist seine schmerzfreie Gehstrecke?
Wie viele Meter kann er laufen, ohne dass es weh tut?
200 bis 300.
Das ist der Begriff der schmerzfreien Gehstrecke.
Dann muss er stehen bleiben.
Beim Treppelaufen, nach wenigen Stufen, tut es ihm weh.
Ja, das war es.
Er wurde 14 Jahre alt.
Er wurde bei ihm über die Tunis festgestellt.
Ja, er wurde bei ihm.
Und vor 15 Jahren wurde bei ihm Diabetes-Melutus-Tipp 2 festgestellt.
Und vor zehn Jahren wieder wurde bei ihm Blutvertwerte hoch festgestellt.
Wurden bei ihm erhöhte Blutvertwerte oder Tagbetriebe?
Hyperkulesterolöse festgestellt.
14 Jahre wurde der Band-Scheiber-Forfall-Lumbar-Herrni-Operation gefeuert.
Seine Mutter hat Diabetes-Melutus und lebt in Pflegeheim.
Sie ist Pflegebedürftig.
Sein Vater ist an die Newcardinfarkt verstorben.
Er hat Stress mit der Arbeit in ihrem Leben.
Er nimmt mit Formin zwei Mal morgens und abends am Tag.
Undrami-Pril, morgens und abends am Tag, ein.
Und Aspirin, er nimmt bei Bedarf ein.
Er rauche Einpackung am Tag seit über 40 Jahren.
Er trinkt ein oder zwei Biage nur im Feierabend oder fest.
Er hat die Drogenfragen verneint.
Also Drogenkonsum wird verneint.
Er hat Penicillin-Allergie.
Er äußert sich.
Die Allergie äußert sich.
Rotes Gesicht und ihr könnt Hautausschlag.
Gut, also mit Irritämen und Gesichtsrötung.
Ja, das war es.
Ja, was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Laut der Angaben, laut ich denke TVT, tief wenn ich drum wollte.
Okay, also muss man jetzt suchen,
dass die Angaben aus meiner Sicht auf TVT sind.
Was wäre Alternative, also Differenzialdiagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose, vielleicht Trombofflebit.
Perletzung, der ist Cellulite.
Der Patient ist starker Raucher, übergewichtig,
erhöht einen Cholesterinwert und hat ein Altersdiabetes
und er hat Bewegungsmangel.
Welche Diagnose sollten wir noch in Betracht ziehen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich lerne für den, die sind so exotisch.
Cellulite lömst für den, da redet hier kein Mensch nur.
Ich habe das auch nicht erzählt.
Liebe Leute, das Ding heißt Claudicatio Intermittence.
Das ist das, was er beschreibt.
Bericht wofür?
Liebe.
Die wurde eingeblendet in verschiedenen Schreibvarianten.
Die Claudicatio Intermittence.
Er beschreibt, dass er Schmerzen beim Laufen hat
und dass er dann stehen bleiben muss.
Und dann gehen die Schmerzen wieder weg.
Woher spricht er das?
Wie?
Er beschreibt eine klassische Claudicatio Intermittence.
Er kann laufen,
wenige 100 Meter,
und dann fängt es an, weh zu tun.
Und dann muss er stehen bleiben.
Wenn er nicht stehen ist,
gehen die Schmerzen wieder weg, dann kann er weiterlaufen.
Wie heißt denn diese Erkrankung?
Claudicatio Intermittence.
Das ist das Symptom.
Wie heißt die Erkrankung?
Das ist eine PAVK.
Peripera-Aterielle-Verschlusskrankheit.
Kam mir gerade,
weil die Leute praktisch unaufwählig vor dem Schaufenster stehen bleiben
und warten, dass die Schmerzen wieder besser werden.
Und gucken sich so lange völlig uninteressante Auslagen an.
Aber sie gehen dann eben erst weiter,
wenn die Schmerzen wieder nachlassen.
Ja, das machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Dopplerutröschal, ich würde sagen.
Ja, aber Sie machen ja erst mal die angekündigte körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja, natürlich.
Wo achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich werde untersuchen, ganz in Körper, besonders bein.
Zuerst inspektion, aus inspektion, gestrullen oder nicht gestrullen.
Sie vermuten ja als erstes die TVT.
Ja, wie ist die Frage?
Wenn Sie eine TVT vermuten,
was erwarten Sie dann beim Aspekt bei der Untersuchung?
Gestrullen.
Ja.
Und erwarten Sie, dass das Bein Blass ist?
Nein.
Rot.
Gerötet.
Ja, gerötet.
Gerötet und gestrullen.
Ja, okay.
Und wo nach gucken Sie noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Entschuldigung, gerötet und gestrullen oder Blass bein.
Er hat gesagt, er ist Blass.
Ja, deswegen wundere ich ja die Verlachtstiagnose, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja.
Also, was machen Sie weiter bei der Diagnose?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Was gucken Sie?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Leiter anders ist.
Ja, natürlich ist es.
Ja, aber trotzdem wissen Sie,
wenn Sie in der Prüfung so einen Fall kriegen,
müssen Sie doch wissen, was Sie machen mit so einem Patienten.
Also, man tastet zum Beispiel die Fußbrüste.
Schaut erst mal, ob das Bein im Vergleich zum anderen dicker oder dünner ist.
Klar, Schwellung.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Sie gucken nach der Farbe und sie tasten vielleicht die Leistenpulse
und die Fußpulse.
Ah, ja.
Ja, und dann kann man auch die Dopplerverschlussdrücke messen
im Vergleich zum Arm.
Ja.
Und dann kann man diesen Arm-Bein-Index,
bzw. Beinarm-Index bestimmen,
um zu gucken, ob der Druck eben im Bein weniger ist.
Gut.
Und dann haben Sie ja schon gesagt, Sie machen Ultraschall,
aber Sie wollten ja auch noch Blut abnehmen.
Was untersuchen Sie denn bei der Blutunterzeit?
Vollblut untersuchen.
Hemogramm,
ich sage ne Appart.
Also Blutbild machen Sie?
So, und dann, wie geht es weiter?
Sie haben doch den Verdacht auf eine Trombose.
Ja, was müssten Sie denn dann noch untersuchen?
Ich weiß nicht, eigentlich.
Die Mehrere bestimmen.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, die Mehrere bestimmen.
Und natürlich, was weiß ich,
CRP,
gut, was bestimmen Sie noch?
Der Mann hat angegeben, er hat erhöhte Blutfettwerte
und er hat ein Alterszucker.
Blutfettswerte, ich warte,
Blutfettswerte kontrollieren, ja, natürlich.
Und?
Was noch?
Blutzucker, Blutfettswerte.
Ja, gut, ja, da sind wir ja schon mal ein Stück weiter.
Und dann wollten Sie natürlich ein technisches Verfahren anwenden?
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, was Sie machen wollen.
Duplexsonografie.
Ja.
Gut.
Und da können Sie einmal, können Sie nach den Wehen gucken
und schauen, ob der eine Trombose hat.
Und zum anderen können Sie gucken,
wie die Arterien aussehen.
Ja, ja.
Gut, und dann ist man ja schon ein ganzes Stück weiter.
Gut.
Ja, also tatsächlich hat dieser Patient hier,
ich mach es mal nicht so spannend,
hat er eine Piafocca.
Also er ist ein klassischer Risikopatient,
ja, übergewichtig, starker Raucher, Diabetes,
Genichbewegung und erhöhte Blutfettswerte.
Ja, so.
Und es gibt für die Einteilung der Piafocca,
gibt es verschiedene Stadien, die Stadien nach Fontaine.
Kennen Sie das?
Nein, ich kenne nicht.
Okay, gut.
Also es gibt vier Stadien.
Das erste Stadium ist eigentlich,
dass der Patient zwar Risikofaktoren hat,
aber noch keine Beschwerden.
Das zweite Stadium ist das, was dieser Patient hier schildert.
Ja, dass er diese Claudikatio-Untamittens hat.
Dass er gehen kann,
dann aber stehen bleiben muss, nach wenigen 100 Metern,
weil er dann praktisch warten muss,
bis die Beine wieder durchblutet sind
und dann kann er weiterlaufen.
Und da macht man eben eine medikamentöse Behandlung.
Das nächste Stadium ist das Stadium 3,
das gekennzeichnet ist durch ruhige Schmerzen.
Der hat also schon in Ruhe im Bett liegen, zum Beispiel.
Oder wenn er sitzt, tut ihm das Bein weh.
Ja, klassischerweise eigentlich vor allem,
wenn er das Bein hochlegt.
Das sind Leute, die nachts aufwachen, weil das Bein weh tut.
Und wenn sie dann das Bein ein bisschen runterhängen
oder auf die Toilette gehen, wird es besser.
Und dann haben wir das Stadium 4,
wodurch die Durchblutungsstörungen die Necrosen auftauchen.
Wo die Haut sich verändert, wo es offene Stellen gibt.
Wo die Zähnen abstärben, wo mit einmal der kleine Zähn schwarz wird.
Oder die Zähnen vorne, die kuppen schwarz werden.
Das sind die vier Stadien und danach richtet sich auch die Therapie.
Gut.
Ja, war offensichtlich für Sie ein sehr exotischer Fall?
Ja, ich bin so begonkelt.
Ja, wir haben am Anfang haben Sie sich ganz wacker geschlagen,
auch sprachlich, was mir da ein bisschen aufgefallen ist,
dass Sie eben auch wieder sehr hartnäckig diese Formulierung haben Sie,
haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie angewendet haben.
Ja, das wäre schön, wenn da ein bisschen Variation drin wäre.
Da fand ich aber, dass Sie sprachlich ziemlich gut waren.
Und in dem Bericht wurde es dann sehr voll berichtet.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie praktisch keinen Satz durchformuliert haben,
wo Sie nicht wenigstens viermal äh gesagt haben.
Ja, also Sie unterbrechen eigentlich ständig Ihre eigenen Sätze
und machen immer äh.
Das machen ganz viele von Ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Das ist also nichts Untypisches, ja.
Aber es, es nervt und ähm, es zeigt ähm, ich mache es selber, ja.
Alle machen es, klar.
Aber man macht es nicht so intensiv wie Sie normalerweise, ja.
Und wenn man so ein bisschen nach Worten ringt,
ist es immer so ein Teil, ne, dann äh, äh, was sage ich denn jetzt, ja.
Versuchen Sie sich feste Formulierung anzueignen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass Sie zum Beispiel bei der,
bei der Familienanamnese, da sind Sie sehr unvermittelt eingestiegen.
Ja, Sie haben also noch gerade über den Patienten gesprochen,
über verschiedene Symptome, was Sie, was Sie überhaupt nicht
weiter erwähnt haben in Ihrem Arztbericht,
dass Sie gefragt haben nach Fieber, nach Luftnot und so,
dass diese Dinge verneint wurden, haben Sie,
der Oberärztin überhaupt gar nicht gesagt.
Und auch ich meine, dass Sie das nicht gesagt haben,
dass er über Kühle und Blässe seines Rechten
Unterschenkels berichtet hat.
Das haben Sie gar nicht, gar nicht weitergegeben.
Aber Sie haben dann über die Vorerkrankung gesprochen,
haben dann unvermittelt über die Familienanamnese gesprochen,
ohne das irgendwie anzukündigen,
dass Sie sagen, also so eine, so eine Standardformulierung wäre,
äh, Familienanamnistisch ergab sich oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Und dann waren Sie einmal wieder bei den Medikamenten.
Die Medikamente gehören natürlich eigentlich direkt
hinter die Vorerkrankung, ja,
dass man vielleicht sogar sagt,
äh, seit 15 Jahren ist ein Diabetes-Meditus bekannt,
der wird aktuell immer noch mit Formin einmal täglich,
übrigens einmal täglich, handelt, ja.
Äh, die Athergellihypathonie wurde vor 10 Jahren festgestellt,
ebenso die Hypercholesterinämie,
das wird mit, ähm, das wird mit, mit denen und dem Medikamenten waren.
Also das gehört eigentlich zusammen.
Und dann muss man aber so eine neue Überstrift setzen eigentlich
und sagen, äh, jetzt komme ich zu den sozialen Komponenten.
Ja.
Also einmal Familie, Anamnese und dann auch, ähm,
aber in der Prüfung, in meiner Prüfung ist bisschen anders,
Prüfung, Method ist bisschen anders.
Wir haben ein Anamnäsbogen
und in Anamnäsbogen, die reinfolge ich so, leider,
äh, und, äh, nicht logisch, das finde ich...
Das ist ja überhaupt nicht logisch.
Logisch, aber leider, so, ja, Vorerkrankung,
dann auch, äh, Operationen,
Familie, dann Medikamente wieder,
interessant, aber...
Das ist ja sehr komisch, ja.
Okay, dann habe ich nichts gesagt, ja.
Also klar, müssen Sie sich dann nach Ihrem Regeln
errichten, wie die das wissen wollen, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, sprachlich war es, war es, ähm, dann natürlich aufgrund der,
der fachlichen Unsicherheit auch, dann im Arztgespräch,
auch zunehmend unsicher, das habe ich gemerkt,
äh, wenn Sie die, die Erkrankung praktisch nicht gut kennen
und diese Stadien nicht kennen
und die typische Diagnostik nicht kennen,
dann sind Sie natürlich auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt,
ne, dann kann man nicht erwarten,
dass Sie dann sprachlich brillant reagieren, ja.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig gewesen.
Gut, ähm, ja, was soll ich sagen?
Äh, am Anfang war ich, war ich sehr überzeugt,
so vom, vom Sprachlichen
und das hat natürlich ein bisschen nachgelassen
dann im Arzt-Arztgespräch, muss ich schon sagen,
aber ich denke mal, das lag mehr an der fachlichen Unsicherheit, ne.
Und da müssen wir jetzt schauen,
dass Sie sich vielleicht nochmal Ihre Mainzerfälle angucken
und sagen, was kann da auf mich zukommen
und sich die nochmal anschauen.
Ich hab auch Mainzerfälle, ich kann mal gucken.
Vielleicht können wir uns noch einmal treffen,
es ist ja noch ein bisschen Zeit, bis zum 17. Februar,
dann äh, haben wir vielleicht nochmal eine Chance
und können noch einmal ein,
ein Mainzerfall zusammen angucken.
Okay, das ist ja, ja, okay.
Okay, alles gut.
Mainzer-Arzt-Arztgespräch dauert sich nicht lange,
nur zwei oder drei Minuten laut der Erfahrung genprüfen.
Mhm, okay, ja, sehr ungewöhnlich, ja.
Fühle ich anders als bei allen anderen.
Ja, ja, ja, äh, ja, uns äh.
Und dann, und dann, ähm,
werden Sie nochmal praktisch
bei einem Patienten nochmal gesehen?
Dann äh, es gibt sechs Schritt,
erst ne Schritt, äh, übersetzen,
latinisch, deutsch übersetzen,
deutsch, latinisch übersetzen.
Oh, sehr schön, ein Buchabitest, ja.
Ja, sechs Schritt, normalerweise prüfen wir es schwer,
aber nur als erstes, äh, ist nicht,
dauert nicht so lange.
Ah, okay, gut.
Wir hören, äh, andere, äh,
die Einladung kommt, äh,
wir müssen etwas notieren, äh, außerhalb der Fall.
Mhm.
Ein Arztbrief äh, lesen,
danach lauft der Arztbrief, äh,
Fragen, äh, beantworten.
Oh, ja, das ist ja völlig anders.
Anders, ja, ja.
Das ist ja komplett anders, das ist ja krass.
Konkret auch.
Aber eine Anamnese müssen Sie erheben?
Ja, ja, Anamnese müssen wir ergeben, ja.
Ähm, ja, aber, ja, das finde ich verrückt.
Wir stellen nicht so viele Fragen, aber äh,
na gut, okay.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Ja, also das ist wirklich, das ist ja krass unterschiedlich.
Ja.
Und äh, also ich finde, das zum Beispiel nicht schlecht,
diese Begriffe abzufragen.
Das machen die, das machen die anderen oft so im Nachhinein.
Das ist im Rahmen des Gesprächs,
irgendwas aufgetaucht, ein Stichwort,
zum Beispiel die Vorerkrankungen, äh,
bei den Vorerkrankungen oder auch bei den Familienerkrankungen,
ist irgendein, vielleicht auch exotisches Ding aufgetaucht.
Und dann fragen, mit die Prüfer, mit einmal nach,
wie wird denn das behandelt?
Ja?
Oder was versteht man denn darunter?
Oder, äh, was, was die auch machen?
Das sieht zum Beispiel jetzt bei der PAVK,
eben nach diesen Stadienfragen.
Oder auch eine Sache, die, die gemacht wird,
ähm, dass sie, äh, dass sie dann im Nachhinein,
äh, Begriffe klären lassen.
Dass sie zum Beispiel sagen, was ist der Unterschied,
ähm, zwischen Akut- und Rehab-Behandlung?
Oder was ist eine Überweisung, was ist eine Einweisung?
Also so bürokratisches Zeug eigentlich mehr, ne?
Also das ist schon sehr unterschiedlich von Bundesland zu Bundesland
und ich glaube auch von Prüfer-Team zu Prüfer-Team.
Ich kann immer nur, äh, ich kann immer nur praktisch
diese Standardfälle so, so demonstrieren,
weil ich natürlich noch nie bei so einer Prüfung dabei war.
Also nehmen Sie es mir nicht krumm.
Und, äh, ja, vielleicht sehen wir uns nochmal
für einen Mainzer Fall in den nächsten Tagen.
Ja?
Okay, okay.